and also see like tiny dot satellites
flying around
well sure yes i wonder if they would be
able to i really think about that like
if they if aliens were to
visit and would they really see humans
as the thing they should be focusing on
i think it would take a while
right because it's so obvious that that
should
because there's like so much incredible
in terms of biomass
humans are a tiny tiny tiny fraction
there's like ants
they would probably detect ants right or
they probably would focus on the water
and the fish
because there's like a lot of i don't i
was surprised to learn that there's more
species
on land than there is in the sea like
there's 90
i think 90 to 95 percent of the species
are on land
or on land not in the sea not in the sea
i thought like there's so much going on
in the sea but no the
the variety that like the branches
created by evolution
apparently it's probably a good answer
from evolutionary biology perspective
why land created so much diversity but
it did
so like the sea there's so much not
known about the sea
about the oceans but it's not
um it's not diversity friendly what can
i say
it's uh it needs to it needs to improve
his diversity but can you do do you
think the aliens would come i mean the
first thing they would see is i suppose
our
cities assuming that they had some idea
of what a natural world
looked like they would see cities and
say these don't belong
which of these many species created
these yeah i mean there's
i if i were to guess it would
it's a good question i don't know if you
do this when you look at the telescope
whether you look at
uh geometric shapes like
if it's uh good because to me like hard
corners
like what do we think is engineered
things that are like have kind of
straight lines and corners and so on
they would probably detect those in
terms of buildings would stand out to
them
because that's that goes against the
basic natural
physics of the world um but
i don't know if the electricity and
lights and so on it could be i
honestly could be the plate tectonics it
could be like
that uh the like the volcanoes that'd be
okay that's the source of heat and then
they would focus
they might literally i mean depending on
how alien life forms are
they might notice the microorganisms
before they notice the big like notice
the ant before the elephant
because like there's a lot more of them
depending what they're measuring device
we think like size matters but maybe
with their tools of measurement they
would look for
quantity versus size like why focus on
the big thing
focus on the thing that there's a lot of
and when they see humans depending on
their measurement devices they might see
we're made up of billions of organisms
like the fact that we have we're very
human centered we think it we're one
organism but that that may not be the
case
they might see in fact they might also
see like a human city
as one organism like what is this thing
that like
clearly this organism gets um
aroused at night because the lights go
on
and then uh and then it like it sleeps
during the day
i don't know how like what perspective
you take on the city
you